Why Is It Illegal to Remove Your Mattress
and Pillow Tags?
A question we’re often asked is why is it
illegal to remove pillow and mattress tags.
If you also have found yourself wondering
this, wonder no more.
Unbeknownst to many innocent consumers out
there, the warning that it is unlawful to
remove the tags from a mattress or pillow
is not for them!
It is for pillow and mattress sellers only.
The specific US Code we’re dealing with
here is Title 15 – Commerce and Trade, Chapter
2, Subchapter V – Textile Fiber Products
Identification, Section 70c – Removal of
stamp, tag, label, or other identification
Statute (a) Removal or mutilation after shipment
in commerce.
This states:
“After shipment of a textile fiber product
in commerce it shall be unlawful, except as
provided in this subchapter, to remove or
mutilate, or cause or participate in the removal
or mutilation of, prior to the time any textile
fiber product is sold and delivered to the
ultimate consumer, any stamp, tag, label,
or other identification required by this subchapter
to be affixed to such textile fiber product,
any person violating this section shall be
guilty of an unfair method of competition,
and an unfair or deceptive act or practice,
under the Federal Trade Commission Act.
“
This became the law in the early 20th century
when the US government responded to concerns
that some of the materials used in pillows
and mattresses easily conducted illnesses
or harbored pests such as lice.
Some manufacturers would stuff their goods
with just about anything including horse hair
or corn husks, since the customer could not
see them.
As such, with the new law mattress and pillow
manufacturers were required to clearly define
the contents of their products and to identify
whether or not these contents were new or
recycled materials by placing tags on them.
This was important as recycled materials could
still contain lice, bedbugs or human excretion.
This information allowed consumers to make
informed decisions about their purchases.
It also meant that based upon their contents,
some mattresses and pillows would not sell.
In order to ensure no pillow and mattress
sellers removed these tags in order to make
the sale, they were stamped, in bold letters,
with a clear message – “Do not remove
under penalty of law”.
The words, “except by the consumer” have
since been added but not a lot of consumers
bother to read the tags in detail.
The myth that it is illegal has been passed
down by word of mouth and through popular
media.
Both the movie PeeWee’s Big Adventure and
an episode of Garfield and Friends feature
characters who were punished for removing
these labels.
Before the words “except by consumer”
were added to the labels, Fred, a character
on a popular 1970s show called Sanford and
Son, removed a warning label, tore it up and
exclaimed, “power to the people!” Johnny
of Johnny Bravo is chased by police in a helicopter
after removing a label from a stuffed animal
and then saying to himself, “Pfft, what
are they going to do?”
Even the mattress company Serta, who are presumably
well aware that it isn’t illegal for consumers
to remove the tags, created a commercial where
its famous counting sheep were thrown in jail
for tearing off of the label after the mattress’s
owner said she didn’t need them anymore.
SpongeBob SquarePants also once asked Squidward
to hide him from law enforcement when he panics
after removing the tag from his mattress.
Although it may not be illegal for consumers
to remove the tags from pillows or mattresses,
it is a good idea if you cut them off to safely
store them with your warranty information.
Many mattress manufacturers, including Sealy,
Serta and Simmons require the tags to be produced
in a warranty claim.